is how do you find everyday ways to feel
creative and a lot of that can come in
the simplest of ways you're building a
deck you're sending an email to a client
and you're like the creativity and how
you're crafting an argument that's
creativity um it might not be
traditional in how you think about it
but it genuinely is creative because
you're you're working a muscle to help
someone understand an argument that you
have or a position that you have on
something and you have to find the most
creative way to make that argument
that's creativity it's really simple but
it's true
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this is all
about creativity meet carolina cruz la
telead partner and managing director of
mutisik hoffer
she has been with the agency for nearly
nine years starting out in 2011 as an
account manager and now serving as
managing director and partner
prior to joining mnh carolina had a
two-year stint at goodw silverstein and
partners working on chevrolet and
denny's
before her time at gsnp she worked at
fuse tv and ad sales helping to create
and build integrated programs for
clients such as burger king kia motors
and mars
carolina is passionate about leading her
teams and being an empathetic leader is
ingrained in who she is so she thinks
she would be a great guest to speak
about how marketing and agency teams
should be treating each other and their
relationships with clients and on her
career and how she rose to become a
partner at the agency
carolina if we're looking at you know
creativity and and you've held numerous
positions across entertainment to
different businesses in in the worlds of
creativity and sales and now most
recently managing director and partner
at motasik hoffer and so you know before
we even dive into your own particular
career
shine some light for me about what
creativity means for
you oh
i love that question
i mean i think when we're talking about
creativity and it relates to the
business that we're doing with the
clients that we're leading
it's just trying to make it a world
where we can find the best ways for
brands to actually outlast culture and
make an impact that people are gonna
like resonate with
um
i feel like creativity can take many
different forms too and i think that's
the fun part of what we do in
advertising is it can be a lot of
different things and it's just about
brands willing to embrace that
creativity can be anything and really
non-traditional paths can make the most
impact
right now it's creativity you know
you've been in creativity for quite some
time
you know if we're looking at leadership
within creativity how does that look
like i mean i understand you know in
software development i understand
building in building companies but
becoming a leader in the domain of
creativity does that mean that you're
necessarily just more creative than
other people that you understand the
world better what is leadership and
creativity look like
i actually don't think that it means
that i'm more creative or less creative
than anybody else um i'm on the business
side of things so typically we're
thought of in the creative industry as
less creative because we don't have
creative in our title
um i actually think it's i know it's
really funny right um i actually think a
lot of it is more about um
creativity and the forms that it takes
and what it takes to actually create
safe spaces for people to be
creative and wacky and wild and dream up
all these things um and really i think
that's what's what the big tension is
right now in creativity in our world is
creating safe spaces for people to feel
like they can
just bring ideas that have never been
thought of or pressure test and have
these collaborative moments with people
um
in in ways that don't feel like they are
tension filled rooms with one alpha that
is telling you what needs to happen it's
it's about um open space
and allowing people to just be
themselves and bring all of that to all
of the creative work that they're doing
every day
so
you know put me into the room where you
know
we're we're figuring out you know the
solution to something and we're coming
up with a creative process and somebody
has found a way to take their own
creative selves and input that into a
story or into an idea
now they're presenting it to a group of
people let's say a board or let's say
just a group of advisors that are going
to give feedback on this idea
how can they do that i mean they're not
in that person's shoes they don't
necessarily understand the whole inner
work that went into this yeah how does
the feedback work in this creative world
yeah i mean i think a lot of it has to
do with how you're even bringing the
creative to the table when you're
sitting in those rooms um so a lot of it
in our world is working collaboratively
with our
who who bring all of the rationale and
the reasoning for why an idea is
incredibly brilliant making sure that
the creative human who's bringing those
ideas forward is working collaboratively
with those strategists to make sure that
when they're bringing those ideas to
board members who you know for example
if you're creating a product and it's
for gen z but you're sitting in a room
with a whole lot of older humans who may
not really understand what that audience
is all about
it's finding ways to help them
understand the magic and the brilliance
of the creativity that's being presented
in the room by giving them a lens to
understand that audience and i think
that's the responsibility of all the
creatives who all are all around the
idea but making sure that we can make
those ideas really come to life in a way
that resonates with people who may not
understand the audience that it's for
and i think that's the biggest
challenges is finding ways to bring
bring that nuance to life for people who
may not sit in those shoes every day
which i think is is a really hard thing
about the industry
right so go back with me to your
personal journey getting into creativity
into the business side of creativity
what is your story
my story's um i feel like my story is
non-traditional and then the more often
i talk to people
they're like oh yeah it was exactly the
same for me
um so i um i went to high school in
south texas um in a little town called
mcallen
and i took a journalism class and i
loved i was on the yearbook staff
like i just like to tell stories it was
just what it was for me i didn't even
realize advertising was a thing to be
totally honest it just wasn't an option
for me
um i ended up going to school in boston
and uh at boston university and there i
um
ended up rooming with a bunch of people
who were in the advertising program i
was actually studying film and
television because i wanted to be a
writer i wanted to write for tv so i
think i've always been in this creative
world just didn't really understand what
advertising could mean for me
um and then just through the
relationships that i built with my
community within the comm school there
started to understand that this was a
thing but still didn't really fully buy
into it
um i graduated early moved to new york
with my girlfriends who were all going
to work in advertising and i was like
advertising oh that looks intense and
crazy and i don't really know about that
um so i ended up working in ad sales at
a company called fuse which was awesome
because it was a music company so you
know you're just surrounded by really
brilliant people just really creative
thinking about how to bring
brands and music closer together so that
was an interesting place to just learn
how to even have that dynamic um
of trying to impact people's day-to-day
lives through really small moments and
how they're watching music television
like what a weird thing to think about
um
and then i moved to san francisco
chasing a boy and
when i got here
um relationship building is as key in
every everything that you're doing every
single day so i had a connection who had
a connection who worked at goodbye and
she was like you need to meet these
people they're great
and i was like i don't know advertising
i don't really get it it's not really
for me it seems intense
and then i took a meeting i was like
i'll just meet some people and i was
really young too so i just the doors
were all open and i was like let me just
see what this is about i've heard of
goody but i don't know anything about
them
fast forward i met the most amazing
people of my life they've fully
influenced everything that i do
and goodbye is a ridiculously amazing
creative agency for somebody who's
really young because you really
understand how that world works
and then here i am and then two years
later i joined a small agency and have
just grown up there and had to learn how
this world works under two incredible
founders
um who kind of took me under their wing
and helped me learn everything so it's
been wild
an accident
it definitely sounds like it took me
back to to goodbye and you're talking
about getting into the advertising space
and the creativity space what what are
you surprised by
what are what are some of those
surprising moments that that left you
thinking like wow like i'm learning
something here that
i really didn't expect to be learning
yeah i mean i think the thing for me um
my two quick years at could be was
how smart people could really be and how
kind they could be in these rooms where
we know we're challenging our clients to
do things that are unexpected and brave
and what it really takes to craft
those conversations
in a way that is meaningful and i think
the the thing for me was kindness like
there was no ego in the rooms that i was
in um we were all genuinely on a team
together trying to figure out how to
how to craft our story so that we can
make sure that our clients understood
why we were tackling their challenges a
certain way and i think i don't know why
but from the world of sales where
everything's incredibly competitive
coming into a creative field where
people were genuinely on one team trying
to make happen was for me like
uh eye-opening moment where i was like
you can be in a room with people and be
like let's do this together like it's
great and doing like really fun creative
big things which i think was actually
super fun when you're like in your late
20s or like let's like throw cars off of
bungee jumps like let's do that that
sounds great
incredible yeah unbelievable okay so
tell me about the last 10 years
you're mentioning that you're joining
these founders you're growing through
the organization
you know it's all happening you know
sort of by accident but you're but
you're absorbing the world around you
you're advancing with it you're gaining
a knowledge and understanding about it
what were these 10 years like what did
you learn in these 10 years yeah i think
the biggest thing for the last 10 years
of just working really closely with
founders
um very entrepreneurial founders as well
is i've soaked up some of that
so
understanding that you
are fully in control of everything that
you can do
um understanding how to have the right
relationships in the room how to read a
room eq
um is so critical when you're talking to
because a lot of the relationships we
were forming in those first few years
were with startup founders in the
silicon valley as well trying to like
get their up and running and we're
looking for an agency who's small enough
to
to help them on their journey um and i
think a lot of it for me was was finding
out a problem and not running away from
it because when you're a really small
company there you don't have an army of
people behind you so you have to be on
the front lines and understanding how to
do a little bit of everything
and i think that's really
the thing that for me has been the most
meaningful my career is
is wanting to learn enough and be
curious enough to know how to have a
conversation about every little little
nuance in the industry and not rely on
everybody around me to do it because we
might only be 10 people
so you kind of have to know how to do it
all um enough
of it all and knowing when to lean on
the experts to actually bring something
in and land it because i think um it's a
team sport all you know all in all it's
a team sport
right now you've held
seven positions at least according to
linkedin
these are just titles but
over the last 10 years you've or 10 and
a half years you've really grown with
the organization and grew yourself
you know as a leader from a account
manager account supervisor account
director group account director director
of client services partner director of
client services and managing director
and partner
you know this show is about leadership
in the end and you know that obviously
that begs the question of
you know how
you know how do you grow as a leader
within an organization like this a very
entrepreneurial organization not coming
from this world having just two years
prior to that in a similar space
oh and but but still growing as a leader
there what what what is their story
what's happening there yeah i mean i
think a lot of the leaders within our
organization
um themselves are always looking to
build others around them up
so
you're you're trying to build the next
generation at all points and i think
that's really critical because when
we're a small organization you can't be
in every room
so you have to build a team around you
that you trust and give them the room
to actually do what they want to do and
do it really well and i think a lot of
our success has come from the fact that
um while we're a small team
we build a level of trust in our folks
so that they can go and run and do what
they do best
and not feel like they're micromanaged
in any way and i think that's where you
tend to get people who who can be really
highly valuable to an organization as
you give them the room
um and then let them fail and that's
okay you learn a lot from failure as
well um and i think that's something
that we're we're not we don't shy away
from that because if if you're not
failing then you're never gonna really
win because you have to learn from all
every single moment and every
interaction
right if you have to think back to the
biggest challenge you've had in the
growing pains of becoming
an executive within an organization like
this growing
from super v to supervisor
what were those challenges like yeah i
think
a lot of the challenges and
and i think about this a lot right now
because i have a team of people who are
going through it actively like i'm an
account suit but i want to be an account
director what does it look like
and there's a lot of tactical things on
a sheet of paper which is man you know
that needs to happen
but when you're talking about leadership
i think a lot of it is is more about um
knowing how to identify
what the strengths are in those around
you
how to work through people's
things that need to be worked on and how
to help build them up
um and i think a lot of the challenges
that i've faced is just making sure that
we're
we're always considering
the people
and making sure that we're we're taking
care of those people and i think the
last two years that's been ever even
more emblematic so
for us a lot of those challenges have
come in really heavily in the last two
years it's just understanding what does
leadership mean now when we're in a
we're faced with the greatest turmoil
that probably all of us have ever had to
face
and making sure that our people still
feel really cared for and and then
ensuring that at every level anybody
who's who has people reporting into them
can take what we're doing up here
and that level of care
and making sure that everyone every
single person's feeling that from
someone above them because that's how we
create an organization that people want
to stick around at and create their best
work at and i think that's where you get
to the best creativity is when people
feel feel cared for and safe
and that's when you're going to get the
crazy things that brands are looking for
well one of the things that you
mentioned that i that i loved is that
you thrive in chaos and you're
comfortable wearing many hats a crisis
negotiator peacemaker and master of
communication
true
i love that first of all i i really love
that
and
the thriving in chaos
you know and tying back to this idea of
creativity look me in there
i mean i live it every day
so we could have a like a three hour
conversation about it
i think the reality is um brands and big
brands small brands we'll talk about the
work for a second big brands small
brands
they have a lot going on within their
organizations they don't have to worry
about creativity every day that's why
they have people like us we actually can
be the ones to push them on the
creativity side of things
but sometimes the chaos just comes from
trying to find the one hour in their day
to say like okay let's put everything
else aside and just think about the
creativity needed to move your brand
forward based on the challenge that
we're all working through right now so
like that's like your everyday chaos um
and then i think the other thing is
and again not to go back to the last two
years but and because it's always been a
constant but when you're trying to do
incredibly creative things there's a lot
of people involved you have production
houses and music houses and
research companies and all kinds of
things
and i think it's getting all of those
things to come together with and there's
always a state of chaos and just making
sure that everything can co all the
connection points come
come to a place where you're landing the
plane so to say and and ideas are coming
to life the way that you've imagined
them to be
um and so that state of chaos is
constant but it's good chaos like you
want to be in the thick of all of that
madness because i think that's where a
lot of the brilliance comes from
i love it
carolina i i really want to
finish the the conversation about
creativity and about leadership taking a
little bit step further you know right
now it feels to me that
creativity and the you know working in
creativity is is sort of meant for some
people and then there's
the majority of others which is just not
creative and anything in
any any position that requires
creativity
if we don't have creativity in our title
we sort of stay away from it i can share
that about myself
i don't want that either i want to be
able to exert creativity in in things
that i do without
having the pressure of titling myself
creative or not creative that puts a lot
of pressure so
give me your two cents about this
our ability to be creative without
necessarily the title of creative i mean
i i consider myself that person too and
a lot of the humans on my team who are
business-minded
see themselves the same way
i think creativity doesn't have to exist
in these big moments where you're
writing scripts and directing
different content pieces and things i
think it can come in the really small
moments we talk a lot about that at our
agency is
is how do you find everyday ways to feel
creative and a lot of that can come in
the simplest of ways you're building a
deck you're sending an email to a client
and you're like the creativity and how
you're crafting an argument that's
creativity um it might not be
traditional in how you think about it
but it genuinely is creative because
you're you're working a muscle to help
someone understand
an argument that you have or a position
that you have on something and you have
to find the most creative way to make
that argument that's creativity it's
really simple but it's true
my cfo's always like there's creativity
everywhere even in the numbers and the
financials and i'm like oh that's scary
but it's true i mean like you look at a
different rapport and you slice it a
different way and that's creativity what
what am i trying to show and then how do
i get that across to our audience in the
most impactful way that's creativity i
don't i think the word is loaded for a
lot of reasons because you have a lot of
powerful humans who are doing truly
creative things but i also love that in
2022 and beyond creativity can be
defined in a million different ways um
and it doesn't have to be in traditional
senses and i think that's actually
what's exciting is that i don't even
know what creativity's going to be in 10
years but i'm like here for it
i love it i don't know what it's going
to be in 10 years but i'm here for it
carolina thank you so much for joining
me for taking the time and to share with
your perspective your personal journey
and and everything in between so thank
you very very much and
continue on your amazing journey and
stay safe and stay healthy it's been
amazing thank you so much
[Music]